F now this is a fairly long one for
marks so we'll go through fairly slowly
and make sure we methodically get
everything right a spherical balloon is
being filled with helium at the rate
given by DV on DT equals four PI R
squared so before we go any further
let's just see what that means when you
see DV on DT we're used to seeing dy on
DX that D stands for Delta which means
change you might recognize that from
some of the chemistry equations you've
been writing over the last few years so
this is really a change in Y divided by
or compared to a change in X now that's
a bit of a mouthful so usually we say
change in Y it's a vertical change right
we usually call that rise and change in
X that's a horizontal change we would
usually call that run so that's what it
really means dy DX change in Y compared
to change in X when you see DV on DT
what you're really seeing is change in V
volume divided by or compared to change
in T which is change in time so how is
the volume changing over time that's why
it's being inflated it's being filled
with helium and this is the rate four PI
R squared the question continues V is
the volume of helium in the balloon
after T minutes and R is the radius in
centimeters where our equals one over
four or a quarter T find the volume of
gas that's been pumped into the balloon
when T equals six assume the balloon was
initially deflated leave your answer in
exact form that's a lot to take in
so before we start let's try to map this
out okay there's four big pregnant
segments is here and in this last bit
that says leave your answer in exact
form so we need to really zero in on
what are the most relevant details now
clearly this rate of change TV on DT
equals four PI R squared we're going to
need to use that you can also see that
there's this critical equation here R
equals 1/4 T which relates the radius to
the time there's a there's a time here T
equals 6
they also go out of their way they say
at a whole sentence assume the balloon
was initially deflated and then the last
thing is well what's the question
actually asking what do they want like
the final line should be something
equals something what is that something
that they're trying to determine you can
see it in that second last line there it
says find that's obviously a key word
that's very important which can help you
zero in the most important part of the
question find the volume of gas that has
been pumped into the balloon when T
equals six now we know the volume of gas
from the earlier part of the question
it's a V right so my final line is going
to be something like V equals something
or other how do I get to V equals well
I'm going to start from this rate of
change devient DT if I were
differentiating from V I would get to
devient DT but I don't want to go in
that direction I want to go in the
opposite direction so I'm going to
integrate from DV on DT to get up to V
the volume of gas okay so I've mapped
out a path through the question I want
to find volume that means I need to
integrate DV on DT there's just a quick
problem before I do that if I were to
integrate DV on DT it's 4 PI R squared
but then I'm integrating with respect to
T and I get that from this original
derivative here it's DV on DT after all
now this is a problem because I'm
integrating with respect to T time and
then I look at the thing I'm supposed to
be integrating and I'm like there there
are no T's in there how am i integrating
this I've got ours instead so I need to
change ours and replace them with
something connected to T and that's
where this line in here comes in R
equals 1/4 T so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to replace everything to do
with our width T by writing this
equation here DV on DT equals from the
original question four PI R squared but
I know that R equals 1/4 T so therefore
I'm going to write it's equal to 4 PI x
one over for tea all squared okay so in
fact I'll leave em write them in the
same color so it's a bit clearer that
r-squared is being substituted for a
quarter team or squared alright so now
let's tidy this up a little bit I've got
four pi times the quarter is being
squared so that's one over sixteen and
then the T is being squared so it's T
squared I can simplify 4 times 1 over 16
that's 1/4 so what I'm getting is PI T
squared divided by 4 ok so this is what
I can now integrate DV on DT because now
the right hand side is in terms of
today's so now let's have a go V is the
integral of this pi T squared on 4 with
respect to time and remember I know it's
with respect to time because that's what
the original line told me up here DV on
details so that's how I know what to
integrate with respect to let's have a
go at this integration the PI over 4 I'm
not going to worry about that too much
for now because just a constant so I'm
just gonna write that out the front PI
over 4 and then it's got a T squared
well T squared is going to integrate
into T cubed then I divide by the new
index so T cubed on 3 plus C let's just
tighten it up a little bit PI T cubed on
the top 12 on the bottom plus C so this
is my expression for volume now this is
good progress because I'm supposed to
find a volume I'm supposed to find the
volume when T equals 6 but I can't do
that yet because I've got this pesky
plus C this constant integration hanging
around now if you have a think back to
our earlier question that one of the
multiple choice the way that we evaluate
a constant integration find out what's
it equal to C equals 3 C equals negative
7 the way we use the question is to find
some extra piece of information in the
initial question earlier on it was a
coordinate that the graph passed through
in this case the question tells us
assume the balloon was initially
deflated initially deflated so there's
an equation hiding actually a pair of
equations hiding in that sentence but
you've got to be able to interpret and
see through the language that the verbs
that are there right initially initially
is a statement about time at the
beginning so that's a statement of t
equals zero
that's what they mean by initially we
set time to equal zero if the balloon is
deflated that's a statement about volume
how much air or in this case helium how
much helium is a minute and the answer
is there's no helium in there V is also
equal to zero if the balloon is
initially deflated so I can use this T
equals zero and V equals zero to
evaluate plus C like what is that equal
to so I'm gonna write when T equals zero
V equals zero I'm just gonna do a
straight substitution I did zero on the
left hand side pi times 0 cubed all
divided by 12 plus sin you can clearly
see all of that stuff up here in this
fraction here that's all just going to
become zero so therefore C is also equal
to zero that gives me an expression V
equals PI T cubed on 12 my plus C has
just become plus zero so I have an
expression an expression I should say
for V and now I need to return the
question one last time to say well when
are you interested in and it's when T
equals six if I substitute that value in
I'll get a volume so let's do that what
I've got here is pi times I should say
when T equals six B is going to equal to
now let's do the substitution five times
six cubed over 12 and you can go ahead
you can pop that into your calculator
I'm gonna try and do this mentally
because it's always really handy if you
can do things in your head the faster
you can do things and the more you can
check areas the more handy that will be
12 is 6 times 2 so I'm gonna do a bit of
canceling here cancel cancel 2 cancels
leaving us
so that means I just get left with PI
times 3 times 6 that's 18 pi and because
we're being asked for a volume I would
say therefore the volume is 18 pi and I
need to search for some units so let's
go back to the question the question
says the radius is in centimeters so
this must be if the volume is you know
radius cubed or 4/3 pi radius cubed then
this volume here will be in cubic
centimeters and we're done so this is
quite a piece of work to get through
here we need to think about how do we
use all of the questions information you
can see I highlighted underlined I saw
all the bits that I needed to fit
together and you've got to work out
what's your end point in order to work
out where are you going to begin and
that was where I focused on that word
find find the volume I'm going to look
for something to do with V so therefore
I'm gonna take this derivative and I'm
gonna integrate so that's how I charted
my path through the question